we are probably losing all sorts of
incredible talents because they are
having to produce uh just really Bland
um stand up if I were a young stand-up
now coming up through the ranks there's
no way I mean the industry has made it
absolutely clear you've got the comedy
industry website chortle which is
completely ideologically captured and
very intolerant of it's very illiberal
in its nature you've got Nika Burns who
was head of the Comedy Awards making a
speech to launch the 2018 Edinburgh
Festival where she said she was looking
forward to Comedy in the new woke world
she said I'm looking forward to these
new woke Comedians and those were her
words not mine she said the woke
movement should be setting the
parameters of what is acceptable to say
on stage when the one of the top figures
of The Comedy industry makes a speech to
launch the largest Comedy Festival in
the world saying that is what we expect
from you that is an edict from high and
it was observed